Hello, and
welcome to your
first epidemiology
lecture.
There are several
objectives for this
session that I hope
that you will be able
to achieve by the
end of this lecture.
You should be able
to define basic
epidemiological terms,
as well as learn more
about study designs
for any given
circumstance. You should
be able to calculate
some basic epidemiological
measures and
defend these in
terms of discussing
different diseases.
and you should be able
to interpret these
different measures.
So just to summarize
what we'll start talking
about, epidemiology
is the study of the
patterns, causes, and
effects of health and
disease conditions in
different populations.
There are several measures
that you must know.
So we will go ahead
and just start with
some of the more basic
of these measures and
then continue on to
more complicated topics.
We're going to begin
our discussion with
talking about rates
and epidemiology.
So let's start with a
seemingly
simple question.
If five different
people today have told
me that their allergies
are out of control,
does that mean something
is going on with the air?
Well, this is a
fairly common thing
that happens. Maybe
you're talking to
your friends and
you mentioned that
everybody you know
is getting sick.
And this is a count.
A count is the
simplest and most
frequently performed
quantitative measure
in epidemiology.
It refers to the
number of cases of a
disease or other
health phenomena being
studied. It's actually
very significant for
rare diseases or
symptoms such as Ebola.
So if someone
says to you, I've
heard that two
different people at
our university got
Ebola this week,
that would mean
something to you.
However, when it's
something common
like allergies,
it may not mean
the same thing to
you. At this point,
what becomes
important is a rate.
So a rate, by definition,
is a ratio that
consists of a numerator
and a denominator,
and in which time forms a
component of
the denominator.
In epidemiology,
it contains
the following elements.
Disease frequency,
unit size of the
population, and the
time period during
which an event occurs.
So the first
thing we're going
to talk about is
incidence rate.
The incidence rate
is the number of new
cases of a disease
that occur during
a specified period of
time in a population
at risk for developing
the disease.
Now, that's a fairly
simple sounding
definition, but there
are several things
that you need to
pay attention to.
Now, the first thing
I'll mention is that
incidence rates are
usually pretty small.
It's very rare
that you hear about
huge numbers of people
getting diseased.
So when you
look at a whole
population, you may
come up with incidence
rates that are
things like 0.0003.
Now, usually it's very
hard conceptually to
think about a human
being in terms of a
decimal. We're really
used to talking about
full human beings. So
normally you're going
to see that number
multiplied by a thousand
or a much bigger number
so that you can say
something like one in
every thousand people
have a new incidence
of this disease. But
remember I said there
are a lot of things you
have to pay attention
to in this definition.
The first thing is
that what defines an
incidence rate is that
it is new cases of
diseases only in your
specified time period.
So it doesn't include
the people who are
already there, who
already had the disease at
the time that you
started your time count.
The incidence rate
is a measure of risk.
This is really what
tells you in a given
time period what are
the chances that you
could get this disease.
The other thing to
really pay attention to
is that the denominator
is the number of
people who are at
risk for developing
the disease. Not every
person is at risk for
developing every disease.
So if you're
calculating an incidence
rate of uterine
cancer, the denominator
should only include
women and they should
have a uterus. So you
have to make sure you
found out whether
or not they had a
hysterectomy. And if
they don't have a uterus,
then they wouldn't be
in your calculation.
So an example of this
is a number of new
cases. Let's say in
this case, it was 1,085.
And you divide that by
a total population at
risk, which was 37,000.
And you see, you get
this kind of tiny
number 0.02924. And it's
really hard to tell
somebody that you're
going to have an incidence
rate of 0.029. It
doesn't mean that much
to people. So it makes
a lot more sense to
multiply it and say per
10,000 women, 292 might
get uterine cancer.
Now, I said that when
you're calculating
incidence rate,
you can't count the
people who already
had the disease at
the time you started
your calculation.
Those people go
into a separate type
of rate called the
prevalence rate. The
prevalence rate
is the number of
affected people in
the population at a
specific time divided
by the number of
people in the
population at that time.
Now, a common question
I get is, does that
denominator also have
to be only people
at risk? And the
question is a good
question, and the answer
is that it depends.
Either way, you just
have to specify exactly
what your denominator
is, and some of it
depends on context. So
when you're talking to
a medical population
and you're trying to
describe how a disease
is occurring, it makes
a lot more sense to
say, this is the number
of affected people in
the population out of
the number of people
who even had the risk
of having the disease.
And you can specify
that. But let's say
you're going to the
government to say, I need
you to give me money.
Then they may want
to know, well,
what are the
number of affected
people out of
all of my voters?
Either way, there are
different circumstances.
You may use different
denominators, but
the important thing
is to always specify.
And this is different
than an incidence
rate where it is always
new cases divided
people who are
actually at risk for
the disease. And the
reason, again, is that
incidence rate is
a measure of risk.
Prevalence rate is
not a measure of risk.
This is just trying
to tell you what
is the cross-section
of the proportion of
population that is
affected right now.
Again, the interpretation
of prevalence
really is just there to
tell you the indication
of the extent of the
health problem. If
you find out the
prevalence of diarrhea in a
children's camp on
July 13th was 33%, then
you might be concerned
as a parent. You might
look at it in a
certain period of time
and talk about it as in
a specific period the
prevalence of cancer
in women was, whatever
it was. But either
way, it's really there
to tell you what the
burden of disease is.
Now, there is a
relationship between
incidence and
prevalence. You can do it
mathematically and see
that prevalence equals
incidence times the
duration of a disease.
So again, if you're
asked what kind of
rate could tell me
what my measure of
risk is, how likely am
I to get this disease?
Assuming I'm at
risk, this is only
the incidence rate.
This is the only thing
that measures the
rate of new cases.
Prevalence measures
existing cases.
Now, what if you're
trying to calculate
an incidence rate and
you just don't have
very good information
on the people in your
denominator, namely
the people at risk?
So maybe you tried
to keep track of
the people at risk,
but some of them
stopped reporting
to you, some of them
moved away, and now
you're worried that
your numbers aren't
really accurate.
So one thing you
can do is instead of
treating your denominator
as the number of
people at risk, you
can assign them person
years. What this does
is gives every person
credit for the amount
of time that they
were actually followed.
So you'd still look
at your number of
people who reported a
disease, but instead
of saying that it is
out of the people
who are at risk, you
would give each person
a number of years that
they contributed. So
if one person gave
you a year, they'd get
one person year. If
another person kept
in touch for five
years, then they'd get
five years, but there
are some problems.
So one person at risk
who was observed for
five years has given
you five person years,
but if five different
people at risk each
gave you one year,
that also counts as
five person years. And
at the end of the day,
five years from one
person isn't actually
the same as one year
from five separate
people. So it's no matter
how you do it, there
are always going to
be some problems and
there is no perfect
way, but this is just
an alternate way of
doing things. We're
now going to go over a
fictional case for the
purposes of talking
about incidence and
prevalence. So let's
imagine you're a first
-year emergency medicine
resident in Los Angeles,
and your attending
has asked you to
help her investigate
the behavior of a new
illness and assist with
public health solutions
to this disease.
So this is what you
already know. The
new illness causes
high fevers, headaches,
seizures, and in
many cases, death.
The illness is unique
in that it also
presents with a
blistering red raised
rash that often
appears in streaks.
Most cases first
present in the emergency
room as the disease
progresses rapidly
once the initial
symptoms appear.
There is some
suspicion that this
illness may have
originated in Senegal,
as many of the
individuals seen with
the disease have
visited the country.
So you start to gather
information. You
learn that there are
no estimates available
for the incidence rate
of the disease, but
the disease-specific
mortality rate in the
population due to this
disease is thought
to be two per a thousand
people. The disease
is considered severe
and lethal, and
reportedly people die
shortly after diagnosis.
So now, using that
information, could you
estimate the incidence
rate? Well, here's
what we know is that
for a severe disease,
mortality rates can
serve as measures
both of disease
severity, but also of
incidence rates. The
idea here is that if you
have a disease that
people definitely
die from, then it can
be a surrogate because
everybody who died
of the disease
obviously had the disease,
and now the incidence
rate would equal what
the fatality rate
is. So case fatality
is a term that's
talking about cases
where people die very
quickly and time is
implicitly expressed.
It's not even really
included because the
idea is somebody gets
sick and then they die.
So in this case,
you could estimate
the incidence
rate to be that
rate, which is
two in a thousand.
So now let's say upon
investigating further,
you realize that the
mortality rate people
are quoting may not
be entirely accurate.
it. So while there
has been an attempt to
calculate the actual
incidence rate, it's been
complicated by an
inability to keep track of
all the people in the
LA population. Some
people moved or they
were just lost to follow
up. So now is there
an alternate way of
calculating this incidence
rate when the number
of people who were at
risk for the disease
weren't all followed
for the same time
period? And this is
where you can use person
years. If you only have
a certain amount of
time from certain
people, you can take that
amount of time and give
them credit for that.
So now let's just
say a cure is quickly
developed for this
disease. So therefore,
the disease no longer
exists in the person.
What would that do to
the prevalence rate?
And what if instead
of actually curing
it, you developed a
treatment and now it's
still there, but it's
no longer deadly. And
what would happen to
prevalence then? So
this is an important
concept because you
can't simplify by
saying when a prevalence
of a disease has
decreased, it's always
good. And that when
it's increased, it's
always bad. Unfortunately,
if somebody dies,
then the disease is
also gone, in which
case the prevalence
would decrease. But it
could also be that
you developed a cure,
in which case the
prevalence would decrease.
But if you just manage
to treat it, then
the prevalence would
actually increase.
But it could also be
that the disease is
getting worse and
therefore the prevalence
is increased. So
you really need more
information than just
rates. So really, what
can lower prevalence?
Death or cure. And
those are very, very,
very different things.
So you need to look
beyond the numbers.
So does an increase
in prevalence mean the
problem is getting
worse? Well, I have to
say that if you were
looking at like a news
outlet and they're not
scientifically trained,
that may be how they
interpret things.
But for example, when
insulin first became
available, the prevalence
of diabetes increased.
The disease was not
cured, but it was
controlled. And many
people who formerly would
have died now survived.
So the prevalence
increased and it was
actually a positive.
So upon studying what
you can about this
disease, you learn
that this disease
has always been present
in small amounts
in Senegal. There
appears to be no increase
in disease rates
there at this time.
This brings us to the
terms endemic, epidemic,
and pandemic, all
of which people have
become very familiar
with in recent years.
But it's still worth
going through what
these things are and
how you define them.
A disease that is
endemic is something that
is just habitually
there. It's considered
normal at a certain
rate in that region.
An epidemic happens
when the rates
exceed what you
consider to be normal.
And if this happens
all over the world,
it becomes a
pandemic. So the same
disease can be endemic
in one area and
become an epidemic
in a different area.
Even within a particular
area, a disease
can have a definition
of epidemic if
it's in excess of
what you expect. But
then if it goes back
to kind of a habitual
level, it can become
endemic in that
same place it used
to be an epidemic.
it.
So now in the U.S.,
in our fictional
scenario, given that
there was no presence
of the disease
until recently, the
disease rate is
considered grossly
in excess of what's
considered normal.
Now you learn
that the disease
has also shown up
in excess rates
in Japan, parts
of South America,
France, and England,
and that people are
rapidly dying from the
disease. So now you
do have theoretically
a pandemic. However,
now you really have
to start looking at
your rates and whether
or not you're calculating
your numbers
correctly. And somebody
points out to you
that you can't really
compare mortality rates
between two countries
because they may have
completely different
demographics. For
instance, if you have
one country that's
very, very young in a
different country where
everybody's considerably
older, you might
have some issues
there because the
people who are older are
more likely to die. So
then what do you do?
So what we've talked
about in this class is
a crude rate. And what
a crude rate is, is
that you just take the
numbers you have and
you do simple division.
In actuality, in
real life, you don't
usually use crude rates.
You have to use some
caution because you
haven't accounted for
anything other than the
numbers in front of
you. In real life, there
are often differences
in gender, age, or
race distributions
within populations, and
you have to mathematically
account for that.
Here is where we
would probably be more
likely to use something
called a specific rate.
Now, the simplest
way to do this is to
simply stratify groups.
If you just think
that the rates of
disease are different in
younger people than
older people, perhaps you
can just report two
separate numbers, and
now you have the numbers
in each age group.
That would certainly
solved the problem.
But it can get complicated
when you have a
lot of different demographic
factors that vary
between people. So
here, what you actually
end up hearing about
more often than not is
adjusted rates. So if
you hear about rates
like worldwide cancer
incidences, if you look
at the fine print, it
will talk about using
a standard population
to mathematically
adjust. Now, you don't
have to do that in the
context of our class,
but this is what's
often done, is to take
different populations
and apply them all to
one standard population,
and the goal is to
eliminate the differences
between the populations
and demographics.
You can also use some
other mathematical
methods. These are
called indirect methods
when you don't have
a lot of numbers
available, but the end
result is the same.
It's trying to eliminate
the possibility
that these differences
are because of just
inherent differences
in the population.
We're going to
shift now to
thinking about
disease prevention.
Disease prevention
is categorized in
separate ways.
Primary prevention
is preventing the
initial development
of the disease,
and the biggest
example of this
would be vaccination.
Secondary
prevention is early
detection of an
existing disease to
reduce severity
and complications.
So for example,
mammograms, the goal is to
catch breast cancer
early so that it is
less severe if it's
there when you catch it.
Tertiary prevention
talks about reducing
the impact of a
disease. So basically
early treatment or
better treatment.
So now, if you were
considering introducing
a vaccine for this
disease for those
traveling to Senegal,
what are the different
things you would have
to consider about the
biology of the disease?
And what would you
have to consider about
the behaviors of the
people who would be
offered the vaccine?
Well, for the
biology, you have to
understand the disease
as well as you can. So
first of all, you
need to have isolated
the pathogen. Is it
a bacteria, a virus,
a ******, or something
else? And if it's
a virus, is it DNA,
RNA? Do you know
the genetic sequence?
Does it have a high
mutation rate? These
are all questions
that you're trying to
get the answers to.
Now, the other thing
is that people have
to actually be willing
to be vaccinated.
Herd immunity refers
to the fact that you
may not have to vaccinate
100% of the people.
However,
every disease has a
certain percent that
you need to vaccinate
to actually receive
immunity in the population.
And if everybody
decides they're not
going to do it because
of herd immunity and
let somebody else
do it, now you might
not actually achieve
herd immunity. But the
idea here is that a
group of people can
become resistant if
the majority end up
immune. So this is why
whenever you see vaccine
campaigns, you're
trying to get everybody
to vaccinate where
it can be safely done
and it's possible.
Now, upon questioning
several emergency
rooms in the LA area,
as well as several
primary care clinics,
you learn that there
have been some individuals
who appeared to
become ill shortly
after visiting Senegal,
while others became
sick several months
after living in
Senegal. So why is that?
Well, this has to do
with the incubation
period. This is the
interval from receipt of
the infection to onset
of the clinical illness.
The question is how
long a person should
be in isolation after
exposure to disease.
We're going to shift
from talking about
treating disease or
quantifying disease
and move into
screening. In a perfect
world, you would stop
people from getting
disease at all.
But given that we
don't always effectively
do that, the next
best thing is to
catch disease early.
So screening, by
definition, is
the identification
of unrecognized
disease by
administering a test.
Usually it is not
considered diagnostic.
You really have to
distinguish between a
screening test versus a
diagnostic test. There
are some tests that
are screening tests
that are so good that
some would argue that
it's almost diagnostic.
But For the purposes
of this lecture, a
screening test is
something that is really
meant to put people
in a category of
high risk versus not
high risk. And really
the intent is to figure
out whether or not
you need to proceed
with more intricate
diagnostic tests. The
goal is, as always, to
try to delay the onset
of disease and to try
to improve survival.
It seems very, very
simple, but it's
actually complex. It can
have hidden costs and
risks. So screening
can cause morbidity,
anxiety, and you
have to be aware of
different biases. You
need a suitable disease,
a suitable test, and
more than anything,
a suitable screening
program. If
people aren't
willing to take your
screening test, then
having developed a
screening test isn't
all that useful.
In order to create a
screening test, you
first have to classify
people as disease
or healthy and you
use a diagnostic test.
In this case, you're
assuming there is a
diagnostic test and
it's the gold standard
and it's telling you
that people definitely
have the disease or
don't have the disease.
You then are developing
your screening
test around that. So
you're developing the
screening test,
administering it, and you're
classifying people
as screen positive or
screen negative. You
can see on this table
that you can put this
in a little grid.
And so on the top, you
have the gold standard,
which is the diagnostic
test. And either
the disease is there
or it's not there.
And then you have a
screening test result
where they either
screened positive or
negative. And the whole
point here is to quantify
how well these are
tracking together as
you'd want it to be.
And so you end up with
these categories of
true positive, false
positive, false negative,
and true negative.
The reason that you
see letters with each
of these terms is
that one of the things
that you are going to
have to do is to learn
how to calculate these
numbers if you are
given such a question.
So we do this just
by making it A, B, C,
and D. And then you
have your totals,
which tells you that if
you have a positive
screening result, it would
be the true positives
plus the false
positives. If you have
a negative screening
result, that would be
the false negatives
and the true negatives.
And in every direction
of this grid, you
have things added up.
Now, as physicians,
this is one
of the things that
is going to most
often come up
in your clinics.
You're going to have
to decide whether or
not you want to order
a test, and you're
going to end up caring
about how sensitive
the test is, how
specific the test is.
These things are
going to make a lot
more sense when it's
on you to decide
whether or not you
want to order it.
But for now, you have
to understand it,
at least in terms of
definition, and you
also have to understand
what that means and
what it translates
into as an equation.
So sensitivity is the
ability of the test
to identify correctly
all screened
individuals who actually
have the disease.
You can see that there
is a corresponding
equation, which is
true positives divided
by true positive
plus false negative.
Specificity is the
ability of the test
to identify only non
-diseased individuals
who genuinely don't
have the disease.
So this is true
negative divided by
the true negatives
and false positives.
People often
incorrectly think that
one is the opposite
of the other,
and it's not.
They're actually
two different
measures of a test.
Sensitivity tells
you how well a
test is good at
picking up disease,
and specificity
tells you how well
a test is at
picking up healthy
people. So you
almost have to just
separate those two
things in your head.
but with that said
specificity and sensitivity
are characteristics
of the test most human
beings if a patient
comes into you they're
not asking you what
is the characteristic
of the test you're
running on me that's not
really their question
that's your question as
a physician but the
patient's question is
if i screen positive
what's the chance i
actually have a disease
if i screen negative
what's my chance i really
don't have the disease
that's the question
they're going to ask
you. And these are
different measures. These
are predictive value.
And these measures are
actually more representative
of a population.
So predictive value,
when it's a positive
predictive value,
is the proportion of
individuals screened
positive by the test who
actually have the disease.
Negative predictive
value is the proportion
of individuals who
screen negative by the
test who really don't
have the disease. And
these are the numbers
you most often end up
quoting to a patient.
Now, one of the
things you have
to consider when you're
selecting a test
is reliability.
Reliability is the
ability of a measuring
instrument to give
consistent results on
repeated trials. But
you have to know that
a screening test
that's reliable is not
necessarily also valid.
The best example I
can give people is that
we all know somebody
who's just reliably
annoying all the
time. Are they reliable?
Yes. Are they always
going to annoy you?
Yes. Are they pretty
much always not
valid? Yes. So when
you're picking a test,
you really want to
consider all aspects
of what you're picking.
So now let's just say
you went through this
process, you wanted
to make a brand new
screening test, you
pick out your people who
have disease or don't
have disease, you had
the diagnostic test
to make your gold
standard, yes or no,
now you administer the
screening test and you
calculate a number that
says 80% sensitivity.
What does that mean?
Well, what it means is
that of all the people
with the disease, you
correctly identified
80% of them using
your screening test.
Now, let's say
the screening
test you
developed has 90%
specificity. What
does that mean?
So 90% specificity
means that of all the
healthy people who
don't have the disease,
you're correctly
identifying 90% of them as
being healthy using
your screening test.
So now back to our
case. The next time you
see a patient in clinic
with this disease,
you mention that
you have a screening
test that may be useful
for the other family
members who recently
traveled to Senegal
and the test is both
sensitive and specific.
But your patient and
their family tell
you that they don't
really know what you're
talking about. They've
never heard these
terms, sensitive or
specific. All they want
to know is if they
test positive on the
screening test, what
is the probability
they're actually going
to have the disease?
And in order to
do this, what
you want to do
is to talk about
positive
predictive value.
Okay, so we're going to
shift now to survival.
People get sick despite
all our efforts.
People get sick. Sometimes
they get very severely
sick. And a common
question is, what is
the probability that
having survived a first
year of treatment,
that person will now
survive the second
year? This comes up most
often in cancer, where
a very common question
is, how long am I
going to make it? Am I
going to make it? How
long will I be here?
The follow-up question
to that is, they've
survived to the end of
the first year, then
what's the chance if
they survive to the
second year that
then they're going to
survive to the next
year? So oftentimes you
end up hearing about
five-year survival rate
in cancer, and this
is where that comes
from. These calculations
can be presented
graphically in a
survival curve and there
are multiple methods
to make these curves.
One of the most common is
the Kaplan-Meier curve.
Now, when you're
looking at
results from
screening studies, you
have to consider
a few biases.
The first is lead time
bias. This is something
that you see a
lot in cancer. The
question becomes when
exactly were the groups
you are comparing first
diagnosed? Did the
two groups you're
comparing have different
protocols for their
diagnoses? So perhaps
you're trying to compare
one type of screening
to another. Well,
what if one group
was diagnosed much
earlier? They were very
good at going to the
doctor and getting their
diagnosis, and
therefore it was written
down in their medical
record much sooner.
And now it looks like
their survival is
longer because they've
just had the official
diagnosis for longer.
And now let's say the
other group just didn't
get screened. And
so now it makes it look
like their survival
is very poor, but in
actuality, both groups
may have exactly the
same survival. So
you really have to
pay attention to the
behavior of the groups
that you're studying.
The second kind of
bias is also something
that you see quite often
when you're looking
at cancer studies, but
you have to consider
that screening could
selectively identify
cases of the disease
where there's a
better prognosis. It's
called length bias
because the idea is that
severe disease might
result in early death,
therefore there's
shorter disease length,
and they may never
even make it to
screening. whereas those
people with a milder
disease would be around
longer and therefore
have a longer length
and then they actually
have screening and it
makes it look like
the screening is what
led to survival but in
actuality the milder
disease is what led
to better survival. So
those are all things
that you just want to
think about when
you're really thinking
about the effectiveness
of screening. So now
this concludes this
epidemiology section.
Make sure please
that you understand
all of the listed
objectives and
I will see you at
epidemiology too.